the United States seeks healthy economic
competition with China and doesn't want
to make other countries choose sides
that was U.S treasury secretary Janet
yellen's message during her four-day
trip to Beijing President Biden and I do
not see the relationship between the U.S
and China through the frame of great
power conflict
we believe that the world is big enough
for both of our countries to thrive the
visit was part of a wider effort to
stabilize the bilateral relationship
rocked by a long list of disagreements
ranging from technology restrictions to
the war in Ukraine we hope the U.S said
will take a rational and dramatic
attitude meet China halfway and work
together China wants the U.S to lift
billions in tariffs imposed by former
president Donald Trump and to end
sanctions that have strangled Chinese
technology firms access to
semiconductors but yellin defended those
restrictions they are premised on
straightforward National Security
considerations they're not undertaken to
gain economic advantage over China she
also criticized what she called an
uneven playing field for U.S firms
operating in China and urged leaders in
Beijing to speed up Market reforms
Yellen did her best to convince China's
officials that de-risking or
diversifying Supply chains was different
to coupling but Beijing remains
skeptical it says the U.S is
generalizing the issue of National
Security in a way that is sabotaging
normal trade and economic exchange
Premier Lee Chung told Yellen that
Chinese development offers gains for the
US not risks they also fear is that
those Technologies can be used against
the United States weaponization of
Technology right so I think this is also
a strategy that is uh making policy
makers and observers in Beijing very
there was no big breakthrough but both
sides called the talks Frank and
productive one area of collaboration was
highlighted climate change as the
world's largest emitters of greenhouse
gases Yellen said it was the
responsibility of both countries to lead
the way on this issue one that will be
picked up during an expected visit by
the U.S climate Envoy John Kerry to
China later this month